hi welcome back to another edition of
The Gadget Lab I am my polka Lori and I
am Roberto so on Wednesday apple
released the latest version of OS X its
desktop operating system it is 10.8
mountain lion and Robbie Roberto has
been reporting on it for a few months
now you've been using it I have been and
there are a bunch of features that we're
going to talk about why don't we start
with sort of the overview like what is
the strategy here why what does this
release represent this release kind of
represents to me other people will
probably disagree this sort of merging
of iOS and OS 10 you're moving you have
Notification Center in there now we have
reminders you have notes all these
things that have been on your iPhone for
a few years or few durations are now an
OS 10 and they actually work pretty well
together mmm so to my eyes the thing
that I see is the most exemplary of this
outside of the things you already
mentioned is the iCloud integration the
fact that you can sync things like
photographs and documents that you're
working on not only with your with all
the other computers in your the max in
your home but with your mobile device
that your iPad in your phone and things
like that right yeah so if you're using
any of I work for example right now you
can save items directly into the cloud
or iCloud as they call it initially when
you open it up I kept looking for
something called the iCloud document
services that doesn't exist each
individual app has its own little
document Center so if you launch an app
and you don't know how to get save
something icon or you save something in
the iCloud and you have no idea where
it's at I've got to file open and it'll
pop open a dialog box else it's weird so
there's no there's no central like
repository of everything I've been
working on an iCloud it's h each
individual app has its own repository
that's kind of annoying how long until
somebody make something that does that
for you because I'd like I look at yeah
right you're probably right I look at um
you know things like we will Drive and
Dropbox and they all work the same way
which is you know you can
organize things by folders but there's
one massive store that you go to you see
everything you have saved so that is a
little weird I guess yeah I mean you can
make individual folders inside of each
applications iCloud repository so that's
that's kind of nice but yeah I was so I
was a long time I disc user so having
that sort of area where you just saved
items to I was you know that was gone
and so now it's it's more
compartmentalized I penalty yes how can
my knife um the other thing the other
thing that I that I really like about it
is that now there are other online
services other than I cloud that are
folded into the OS like you talked a
little bit about the Twitter
functionality and the write up that you
did for gradual on yeah you can tweet or
share items you can share I'm just
directly from the finder and tweet
directly from the finder and almost it
you know from folders you can send
documents or links from folders you can
send photos you can you know you can
right click on something and share and
tweet that or you sent through messages
with something I found which is really
fun is I have a folder full of gifts
because i'm a nerd and you can right
click on that share animated gifts not
just any gifts not just regular just
like oh it's not all are featuring cats
that's gonna happen breaking bad some
are Game of Thrones but you can right
click on one of those gifts and Senna
has a message and I message to someone's
iPhone so I've been sending animated
gifts to my wife's iphone for the past
week and I'm sure she loves you and
she's like how do I do this upgrade
afraid it's fun um also flickr you can
you can find an image somewhere anywhere
in your computer and right click and
send it to flickr yeah and the kind of
the weird thing is that you've been able
to send items photos to flickr from
iPhoto for awhile but there they've been
constrained to 124 1024 x 1024 that's
the biggest you can send from iPhoto
unless you have a pro account but from
the finder you can send 2048 x 2048 does
you can send a larger photo
the finder using that share the same way
messages Twitter Flickr email you can
use the same thing upload it and and
when you upload to flickr from the from
the finder you also get the option
there's a description there's titled you
can put tags it's a much nicer
integration with Flickr than I photo
which is the photo document well yeah
yeah I think there are probably a lot of
people who are you know sort of flickr
power users who are going to be using
iPhoto anyway I would about yeah it's
just kind of janky never really been a
big fan of it but yes if you think you
want to put it here it's it's never been
a great sort of integration right
speaking of integration there is no
Facebook integration not now what I've
seen apple said during the keynote that
would be coming in the fall it was
available during the dev builds so
during developer builds you know Pete
that's and he may have seen some people
saying oh it's been pulled well it was
never actually in the gold master I see
so it's it's not there now but it will
be coming in a fall apple said it'd be
coming in the fall so it wasn't pulled
its it's just not yeah it's just not
there right now well so we can still
tweet and we can still flicker yeah
that's good I guess out here to the cows
come home now what about what about
upgrading its its twenty bucks twenty
dollars so it's kind of a no-brainer you
get twenty bucks I mean don't eat pizza
tonight boom you got a new OS so what if
you know I bought my computer 2009 I
never upgraded to lion may be upgraded
to snow leopard like what about all
those issues I would check Apple's
upgrade compatibility charts before you
just go crazy and start upgrading a lot
of anything pre-2011 it won't get
airplane airplane awesome but if you
have a 2010 2009 whatever computer
you're not gonna be able to send your
your your your images or your screen you
can't mirror on your you can do video
video mirror into an apple television
yeah unless you have a newer computer
yeah you need it a newer computer show
and I mean that sounds like sort of an
edge case you know something really
nerdy but that's actually a
awesome feature it is I I think that's
probably the killer feature via on the
upgrade is AirPlay Mirroring because it
creates a situation where everything
that's on your computer anything you can
get to on the internet or if you have
any applications you can put it on your
big screen TV now anything hulu like if
you want to get hulu on your big screen
TV you gotta pay you know it's like
eight bucks a month you can watch any of
the free content on hulu on your big TV
now just by throwing yeah using airplay
exactly so how long until that gets shut
down I don't know technically it's very
difficult to shut that down yeah they
would have to have apples complicit you
know that apple would have to be
complicit in that they would have to
actually you know engineer in that block
right i don't i don't know how they're
what they're going to do about it I'm
excited about you know music festivals
well yeah chela we streamed Coachella
from my wife's iPad way I do all these
crazy workarounds to get Coachella
streaming on the iPad and we push it to
our TV this year we won't have to do
that right we can just watch it on there
we can watch needle live video other day
on watching a live stream of a bear
fishing I started on my big screen TV
I'm sure there was riveting it was well
that's just about all the time we have
right now but I just want to wrap up and
say that we are recommending that you
upgrade and of course back up before you
upgrade that's very important you have
time machine built in so you're smart
enough to know that what do you
recommend by the way do you recommend a
wipe and a clean install or just do the
on top of if you can do a wipe and clean
install it's always a recommendation but
if you can't if you have too many items
too many you know programs applications
you know add-ons if you just you can
just do that I do recommend waiting to a
point one with least a point one update
if just in case okay which is first
adopters is go for it but every official
if you use your computer for work or
you're in the middle of a big project
finish those things but I always kind of
recommend a point one up and that's
usually within a month right yeah okay
and it's only twenty bucks which is like
four double venti do she knows so you
know if you can curb your entry no curb
your starbucks have
for a little bit maybe you can you can
afford the new operating system from for
your computer anyway that's all we have
for this week Robbie and I will be back
next week on The Gadget Lab